did you guys end up watching if i don't
know did you watch it didn't watch that
none of you guys watch this video did
you watch the fight
one of the sickest fights crazy crazy
sickest fights i've ever seen people are
giving deontay wilder crap for not being
a good sportsman dude just took a
beating yeah like what do you want him
to do he didn't know where he was like
do you think he's done deontay
psychologically he's done oh it's a
tough one man i i don't i don't think
he's done per se because that right hand
should have knocked out fury multiple
times if anything he's probably sitting
here like what what's going on have i
lost my powers like i don't i don't see
anthony joshua beating deonte wilder i
just don't know do you want to watch it
i don't i don't because we were trying
to figure out like what's the next fight
i think i i think if i'll check and and
uh and uh fury could be good
that's david and goliath and by the way
that's fine to see that but i tell you
if he doesn't beat fury he's
psychologically done diante wilder if
you're listening to this there's one
fight to make it i don't think that it
is logan paul dante
i don't know we even need to be
mentioning the wild's name no gerard it
has to be all about tyson fury this guy
is by far and away the number one
heavyweight he's making boxing without
freaking tyson fury doing what he do
we'd be talking about by the way many
agree over here many agreements
okay forget about dante walder i don't
care if he stays boxing he's done he's
not fighting fury anymore he's beat his
ass three times did you replace tom
center
you sound like a guy named tom sanders
was always wrong speaking of conspiracy
there daniel cormier who i love did you
hear him talk about how deontay actually
knocked out uh fury that was a a crate
andre ward and daniel cormier going back
and forth on twitter talking about how
long
the uh the standing eight count fury got
on the second knockout what knockdown
was i was like i don't know yeah by the
way you know the dustin portia interview
is going uh uh being picked up all over
espn reached that was espn reached out
to us yesterday they reached out because
they're going to use like 32nd of the
clip because a couple comments he made
he said that the biggest puncher was who
connor he said doesn't matter what year
was he was the biggest puncher he said
khabib he says you don't even know what
to do with that guy with khabib and then
when i asked him the question who would
replace the dana white if dana won they
wanted to step away i said can you see
connor doing it he says no i can't see
connor doing this but i can see daniel
cormier doing it so he's getting daniel
you give daniel some love you know for
replacing smart guy
yeah can you like dc running ufc i don't
see it that's pretty serious yeah but
dana white's not going anywhere not any
time
not any time
dc in the in the booth though i want to
i want conor mcgregor does connor ever
want to step out and want to fight this
does conor ever fight against he's
partying a little too much man his post
yesterday yeah i don't i don't know he's
injured but he's an athlete through and
through he'll come back yeah come on
like yeah connor will come back take a
couple years be confident listen it's
really hard to get up and put in the
miles when you're when you're waking up
satin sheets right pajamas don't put
john i'm calling conor mcgregor out
right now
you want to come back
david
david give it to me
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]